now and ever before seen look at a remarkable
legal event the former president of the United
States under oath being questioned by attorneys
from the New York attorney general's office
invoking the Fifth Amendment over and over
and over CBS News was first to obtain this
video let's bring it to you now with CNN's
Kara Scandal joins us Cara what do we learn
this was a a position that Trump gave in
August as part of the New York attorney
general's investigation and one of the
things that Trump after he kind of goes
through the initial meetings he starts reading
this lengthy statement and he had once said if
you're innocent why would you take the fifth well
let's listen to his explanation of why he did now
anyone in my position not taking the Fifth
Amendment would be a fool an absolute fool
one statement or answer that is ever so slightly
off just ever so slightly by accident by mistake
such as it was a sunny and beautiful day
when actually it was slightly overcast
would be met by law enforcement under the
advice of my Council and for all of the
above reasons I respectfully declined to
answer the questions under the rights and
privileges afforded to every citizen
under the United States Constitution
and so Trump then went on to answer same answer
to more than 400 questions that he was posed over
the course of several hours during that interview
and as you know the New York attorney general's
office did Sue the former president Donald
Trump his eldest children and the company
uh saying that they engaged in a decade-long
fraud she is seeking 250 million dollars now
Trump has denied any wrongdoing but you know
at the outset of this video you can see there
Trump is in the tight shot but you can hear the
New York attorney general Leticia James in the
room addressing him explaining to him how this
deposition will take place and he says that he
understands and he notes that he says he did very
little to prepare and that he didn't do anything
wrong but then he goes on to quote as part of
his statement some of the quotes that Leticia
James had made on the campaign Trail really having
these two people these two adversaries in the room
together where he is quoting back to her what
she has said truly a very unique moment John